Justice League unites DC's mightiest superheroes
in an epic battle to save the Earth from a
deadly threat, and the movie also features
not just one, but two cool end-credits scenes.
Yippee-ki-yay, movie lovers, it's Jan here,
and today I'm breaking down what's in the
Justice League post-credit scenes, what they
mean for the future of DC's cinematic universe
plus some hidden easter eggs you might have
missed.
I'll be talking spoilers for the end-credits
only, not for the plot or the end of the movie.
If you want to avoid any spoilers, tap here
for my spoiler-free video with the Justice
League cast at Comic Con.
I'm also starting my giveaway for two Justice
League: The Art of The Film hardback books
which are loaded with concept art, sketches,
and behind-the-scenes shots from the set.
For your chance to win, make sure you subscribe
and leave a comment about the movie on this
video.
Let's start with the most important end-credits
scene which opens in a prison.
There's a guard wearing a cap with an 'A'
for Arkham Asylum on it, and if you recall
the end of Batman v Superman, this is where
Batman was sending Lex Luthor.
The guard calls over to a bald man in a cell
who has his back to the camera.
When there's no response, the guard turns
the man around, revealing it's not Lex Luthor,
but a another man who starts laughing maniacally.
The scene then transitions to a boat arriving
at an extravagant yacht.
Boarding the yacht, we see the silhouette
of a figure that comic book fans will instantly
recognise as Deathstroke, aka Slade Wilson.
And he's meeting with none other than Lex
Luthor, who's evidently escaped from Arkham.
Deathstroke then takes off his mask revealing
his signature eyepatch, plus grey-white hair
and beard.
Lex Luthor says that with the Justice League
having just formed their own team of superheroes,
he and Slade Wilson need "to level the playing
field [and form] a league of [their] own."
So, this is hugely exciting because it means
we're looking at a supervillain team-up of
Luthor and Deathstroke, plus probably more
villains by the time the Justice League sequel
comes around.
And there are two likely possibilities for
this supervillain league.
The first is the Injustice League which, as
its name suggests, is a kind of opposite team
to the Justice League.
Ezra Miller who plays The Flash has said he'd
like to see the Injustice League in Justice
League 2, although he's admitted he's not
party to DC's plans for the sequel yet.
The second possibility is the Legion of Doom
and there are some hints that suggest this
could be DC's preferred option.
On TV and in the comics, the Legion of Doom
has been a principal team of antagonists to
the Justice League, with Lex Luthor being
the leader in many versions.
And Luthor clearly seems to be the initiator
of the idea in this end-credits scene, plus
as a billionaire he has all the obvious resources
to spearhead such a project.
Most tellingly though is a tweet in early
October by the actor who plays Deathstroke,
Joe Manganiello, where he posted a picture
of himself wearing a shirt with "Legion of
Doom" on the front in a similar style to the
Justice League title.
I also wonder whether the meeting between
Luthor and Deathstroke out on the water could
be a little hint to the Hall of Doom which
has been the Legion of Doom's headquarters
and is often hidden in a swamp.
And, interestingly, in the "Final Crisis"
comic book storyline, the Hall of Doom is
offered to Lex Luthor and his team of supervillains
just before Darkseid's invasion of Earth.
Incidentally, Zack Snyder already teased this
post-credits scene back in September 2016
when he tweeted a photo of a storyboard in
which we can see a picture of Deathstroke
talking to what appears to be a bald man.
Doubtless, many fans will be very happy at
the prospect of Deathstroke coming to a DC
movie in the future, but Lex Luthor was quite
a divisive character in Batman v Superman,
with some fans not enjoying Jesse Eisenberg's
take on the megalomaniac supervillain.
The post-credits scene is obviously very short
so it's hard to judge whether Eisenberg's
Luthor will engage a wider set of fans in
future movies, but the fact that he's out
of prison now also means he's available as
a villain in a potential Man of Steel 2.
Deathstroke, aka Slade Wilson, is set to get
his own solo movie in the DC movie universe
and Warner Bros have been in talks with The
Raid director Gareth Evans to direct the film.
So far we don't have details on whether the
solo movie might be a prequel of sorts to
his meeting with Lex Luthor, in other words
a Deathstroke origin story.
But it wouldn't surprise me if that's what
it is.
By the way, it's possible that the bald guy
in Arkham Asylum in the end-credits isn't
just a random criminal but it could be Mr
Zsasz, a Batman villain and serial killer
who carves a mark into his own body whenever
he kills someone, and who often appears with
a shaved head.
The other end-credits scene is a fun one for
fans and features a Flash-Superman race.
In the scene, Flash jokes that the race isn't
really a "macho measuring thing" to which
Superman quips that if he wins Flash "is off
the team".
The race is a little homage to the discussions
many fans love to have about whether their
favourite character is faster or stronger
than someone else's favourite character.
The scene doesn't really give us an answer
to this debate, ending in what looks like
a tie, in a similar outcome to some of the
Superman-Flash races in the comics.
For example, in Superman #199, the UN proposed
a fund-raising race around the world between
the two heroes.
When Superman and The Flash discovered the
mob had set up illegal bets on the outcome
of the race they agreed on ending it with
a tie, a convenient outcome that ensured neither
set of fans ended up disappointed.
And a similar scenario happened in The Flash
#175 when they raced around the entire Milky
Way.
So, did the post-credits get you hyped for
Deathstroke?
And what do you think about a supervillain
league battling the Justice League in a sequel?
And if you've seen Justice League what did
you make of the movie and how it compares
to Batman v Superman?
I'd love to hear what you think in the comments
below and also make sure you subscribe for
a chance to win one of these two Justice League:
The Art of the Film books.
If you're the person on screen now, then you're
the winner of my Spider-Man: Homecoming Blu-ray
Deleted Scenes giveaway.
Congratulations and make sure you contact
me so I can get your details to send you the
prize.
I've got more Justice League videos on the
way, so turn on your notifications to get
those and I'll also add links here as soon
as they're ready.
If you enjoyed this, I really appreciate your
thumbs-up, and you can check out more videos
you might like here.
Thanks for watching and see ya next time.
Yippee-ki-yay movie lovers!